you know in the 40s you know when the
studio's own theaters there there was
like this sort of cultural generational
shift and everything started to change
in the 50s and so what Hollywood was
morphed into something else and so all
of these new filmmakers kind of came up
out of nowhere
independent guys like you know
Cassavetes and you know they made these
films that weren't as expensive but they
were more authentic and real and they
were gritty and they were about
characters and we got these amazing
actors that came out of that like Dennis
Hopper and Jack Nicholson and then
Hollywood saw what was happening and
found ways to market it correctly and
turn it into an empire and it became
great again you know and then I think
what's happening now is these movies are
they're they're either enormous or
they're tiny you know there's no sort of
mid-level movie anymore
you know they're still out there but you
know they're sort of few and far between
and I think what ends up happening is
you spend so much money on so much stuff
and glitter then the film's they do well
but they don't always do well enough you
know but the thing that's always
affordable is story you know story
doesn't cost a lot you just have to have
one and you have to put it down on paper
and you have to be true to the script
you have to film it well and that I
think will become a very popular
commodity
a wonderful special effect for film is
having a great story she had these
filmmakers now they don't have the money
they don't have the money for green
screens and special effects and you know
robots flying in the sky you know these
guys that are coming out of everywhere
all these different little pockets in
the world they just have a passion for
telling these stories and then making
film there's a lot of really great ones
out there and that's their special
effect it's story that's how they're
gaining their audience so to me that's
that's the big special effect that's the
big up-and-coming special effect in the
film world this story what about for
serialized content because before it was
just sitcoms or you know weekly you know
hour-long dramas maybe but now people
are doing this binge viewing yeah and it
just seems like it's taking over yeah I
think it's great I mean it's great and
again I love television you know so it
is kind of a cool thing to be able to
see an entire season you know in the
course of an evening mmm you know the
watched an entire you know thing play
out III think it's great but again it's
only great if the story's great you know
I mean for the longest time I'm a
perfect example in just how I view
things personally I did not watch The
Walking Dead forever because I have a
problem with zombies in stories to me
it's it's a dumb a zombies an idiot it's
a dumb thing it doesn't it just yeah so
you shoot it and that's it I understand
there's a lot of them but then that just
becomes redundant so I don't see how
it's a good story because a'm be is not
a compelling villain to me because it's
a it's a dumb nothing so it's not a
compelling bit line so you're like hi
you guys like yeah okay so what happens
the zombies come and then they kill the
zombies awesome fantastic
that's good I'll pass and then finally
watched it and it's an amazing story
about survival and desolation it's not
about the somme bees you know and that's
why it's so good because it's amazing
stories and wonderful characters to
watch that play out over the course of a
full season and the serialized drama or
to watch it unfold you know in a film
whether you're watching it on your phone
or on an airplane or in a huge imax it's
great everybody loves a great story you
know you know when people talk about
moments in their lives they talk about
the story of what happened you know it's
like how did you get engaged oh it's a
great story that's what they tell you
they don't just go well here's the ring
I got engaged everybody's interested in
the story of it how did it happen like
what you know you go over to someone's
house and they've got something sitting
on the bookshelf it's like how did you
get that oh it's a great story that's
what we love we that's what we look for
that's what we want you know so yeah you
know have the spaceman fly around and
shoot lasers at the Death Star whatever
just to tell a good story while you're
doing it it's the most important special
effect to me story
you